hey guys matt here code tech tutorials
you know me probably unless it's your
first time here in that case welcome but
i just want to explain a few things and
talk at you for a second and give me
some updates and
give you some numbers i suppose all
right so uh yeah we gotta we gotta do
the channel differently this isn't
working how it is and what do i mean by
that i know a lot of people like watch
my videos and love them and show a lot
of thanks and stuff and i really
appreciate that appreciate you guys and
that does mean a lot but uh like here to
thanks and stuff unfortunately doesn't
really help me uh like pay bills and i'm
kind of uh running at a pretty big
negative so ever since i started like
adding videos on this channel i've
basically just gone in the hole further
and further um i made videos about this
in the past like i i made a video that
you can check out it was probably almost
a year ago now that's like uh
well why you'll never or why being a
content creator isn't worth it or
something like that i don't know but
basically the synopsis is uh yeah you
work really hard you make videos you
slowly grow you slowly grow and like 10
years later you made it but what did you
do in those 10 years you lost money with
every single production and that's where
i'm at i lose money with every single
production every time i sit down and do
an edit that takes a whole day it's
about a 200 to a 300 job and i eat that
cost because most of my videos make
anywhere from 25 cents to 2 bucks and
that's it and i pay
at least 300 to make them usually about
500 when all said and done yeah that
that cute creator video i made costs
about 400 to make the ones i made the
week for that about 400 500 to make the
one before that about 400 or 500 i'm
eating all this costs out of those three
videos i'll probably recoup that money
in
about seven years of those videos being
out but what will most likely happen is
the videos will fall off and stop
getting views and i'll never make my
money back basically so that happens
with every single video that's been
happening continuously for this channel
and i've kind of just ignored this fact
and thought hey maybe i just stick it
out it was kind of like work eventually
and i can't do that anymore i have a
family i have people i need to take care
of and this is draining me heavily and
it's it doesn't really do anything for
me other than give me a few random
online things and a few updates which
it makes me feel a little better but it
doesn't change the fact that i'm just
like draining family savings and it's
gotten to a point where like i don't
want to do it anymore could i do it sure
i'm not exactly poor i'm a programmer
i've made a lot of money but
this is this is just stupid basically
this is a stupid thing for me to
continue and
i'm too nice like i want to do it
because i know like a lot of people
learn from it and appreciate it they
don't appreciate it that much because
the only one paying it is me and it
sucks so
yeah
i don't know what to do about this other
than to quit basically that's like what
i have to do
i guess i can make some of these talk at
you sort of videos without any editing
because that doesn't cost me as much
[Music]
but yeah i don't know maybe consider
supporting me on patreon if we hit a
decent enough number there i'll i'll
start putting time in or hiring editors
or make better content but until then
it's basically over and i don't
particularly care what people think or
don't think about that i don't think it
matters anymore i try to make videos
that are good doesn't really seem to
matter as far as like growth or anything
i mean it does a little bit i don't want
to say it completely doesn't but the
amount of them and the amount of effort
i have to put in to get like an extra
two dollars a month is ridiculous so
basically screw the system i do love you
guys as viewers i really appreciate you
guys but this system in general on
youtube just totally blows basically
it's terrible and i i don't want to do
it anymore at least not in the way i was
doing it i got to stop trying to impress
people what really got under my skin and
there's always some little things here
and there
was
and i i'm not blaming this person it's
just something i realized that made it
click so linus tech tips awesome guy
makes great videos fine videos millions
of subs millions of views per video he
makes this trying linux as a daily
driver video and it is god-awful he has
no freaking clue what he's doing he's
pretty terrible at this stuff in general
thousands millions of views people
reacting to it thousands hundreds of
thousands of views i i made essentially
those same videos like a year ago and
they barely broke 100 views and i
actually knew what i was doing i
actually got everything to work i was
able to play all my games i was able to
just like
just to see that happen to realize that
like i have way more knowledge than this
guy but because of how this system works
i'm never gonna get recognition for it
just
totally sucks and i'm done so a little
of the formula and some number theory of
how things are going to explain what i
mean because i know a lot of people just
probably won't believe it or will say uh
you're just you know whatever well here
is the reality of the situation so i i
made a little formula here switch
on
desmos is it's it's easy okay so here
ignore the graph i'm not really using
the graph but
here's the theory all right
um t t is one month every month so we're
going to go up to 600 months
all right so that's going to be used in
our calculation just kind of like a
monthly so we can get a monthly scale
what's happening
so every month
i approximately make about five dollars
more than the last month so that's why
we have t times five
this is about five dollars more per
month and that should scale over time so
for example one month i might make 200
the next month will make 205. now this
is this is an estimate it's not perfect
sometimes it goes down a tiny bit
sometimes it goes up but it seems to be
about five dollars but more so it's it's
a decent scale you know it's not bad but
here's the thing i make
four main productions every month and
those i'm going to say
cost around 200 each and that is a low
ball number it's probably more around
400 of my time and everything and when
all said and done getting everything
together totally is probably more we're
going to say 200 per for production four
productions per month so four times 200
about 800 a month spent on productions
as a low ball number
and patreon supporters i make about 18 a
month from them thank you very much does
help a lot as you can see and i got
another plus five here for random odds
and ends sometimes people give thanks
and donate a buck or two or something
like that it's not very much it looks
like it's going to be about five dollars
a month that might increase over time
i'm not sure and then we have an
inflation calculation here inflation
inflation's been crazy recently uh it
looks like it's much higher now but i
put it at three percent which is around
here
so
around three percent inflation so we're
going to times this entire thing by 0.97
to take three percent off
and right now
like month one well
okay let's go ahead and scale this up to
where i'm currently out i've been doing
my channel for about
uh three years i think so we'll go i'm
gonna estimate here let's say i'm doing
it for about 42 months that's right
or that's close this is an estimate
number but it still makes the point it's
been somewhere around three years maybe
it's been four i don't know i've sort of
lost track i'd have to go look so right
now i'm operating at a cost of negative
540 dollars per month that's how much i
make on youtube creating content
negative 540
so
yes it is literally costing me a lot of
money to produce this content every
month
and to get into profit i have to do this
for about okay
so at 156 months
i finally break past the zero dollar
margin that's how many months is that
i don't know it's a lot it's something
like 15 years so in like 15 years from
now
at this current rate and who knows
what's really gonna happen inflation
might go higher this might actually stay
five percent which i guess doesn't
change a whole lot of things i might
these calculations might not necessarily
be perfect uh
but it's an estimate
so
yeah in about 15 years i'll finally be
operating at a profit which probably you
know will start making up for all the
negative
in the past so it's not actually gonna
be a profit and to get to my goal number
which is a thousand dollars that will
happen in about
365 months or approximately when i'm
extremely old and venerable
and potentially on my deathbed i will
finally be hitting my gold number
so
that's that's the current trend of my
channel and
that's why i'm quitting because this is
terrible i could probably go out on the
street and beg for money like change
like a bum and make more than i make
here and it sucks it sucks to realize
this it's like a major burn a major burn
on everything i am
and it actually makes me kind of want to
just like break down and i don't know it
sucks as you can see so there's nothing
good about this this is probably the
worst system ever so what would happen
if i just cut the cost i just stopped
making videos i'm immediately in profit
so the the fastest way for me to start
making profit on this channel is to stop
creating content right now
because at least then i don't have any
costs anymore so uh yeah that's where
we're at if you don't want that to
happen i suggest supporting me on
patreon now i could have this number a
little higher there were some people
that wanted to give me more than
others and stuff like that but i didn't
really feel comfortable taking a large
sum from one or two people so i just
made it one tier that's just three
dollars and it's you know it's the price
of a coffee or a beer it's the theory
so if that can manage to increase that
would go a long way towards continuing
this
but that's not up to me like i've begged
and pleaded in so many videos and it's
made zero difference so maybe it'll make
a difference now still not up to me up
to you guys uh what is up to me though
is
whether i stop making these productions
or not and it looks like the most
obvious
choice here is to stop making
productions now maybe my amount of
increase per month will shrink if i stop
making productions but even still
i hit the profit margin way better just
by not making content at this point and
just leaving it where it is so it makes
a lot of sense to quit based on these
numbers now sometimes i see a comment
like oh your content's great you're
going to blow up soon
like i really appreciate that sentiment
but no i'm not it's been a slow grind
since the beginning there's no
indication that i'm going to blow up
anytime soon or ever if it does happen
it is a total stroke of pure luck
there's nothing saying i'm going to blow
up no indication that it will ever
happen i sure i hope that it happens but
that's not something i can rely on or
put into a calculation
so
that's that's the truth that's what's
going on
and it's in your guys's hands right now
because leaving it up to youtube and me
creating the best content i can is put
me in the hole
yeah well
yeah this might suck to hear but at
least uh
i can say that i'm being honest and i do
appreciate you guys as viewers and the
people who care about me that does mean
a lot
there's really no substitute for
the relationships i've gained and stuff
like that that's priceless stuff but
even that yeah that doesn't pay my bills
i'm still going to end up on the street
i'm i'm still going to be homeless
you know that it doesn't help that so as
much as i love you guys i don't really
want to be freezing in the winter
and uh
bumming it for the rest of my life so
yeah i get the obvious thing for me to
do
and it's not particularly what i want to
do i'd prefer to keep doing youtube the
obvious thing for me to do is to quit
youtube and go get a corporate job where
i can i can secure a good stable income
i've done it many times before i've
saved up a lot in the past from it and
i'm sure i can do it again i have no
doubts and that's clearly what i should
do for my future benefit if you think
otherwise let me know